[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the president is going
to be impeached that's the word we heard
from the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi who
effectively confirmed it during a short
address this morning on the one hand the
news is really no surprise at all
approximately a hundred percent of MSNBC
viewers have been demanding impeachment
since well before Donald Trump was
elected president they'd be baffled and
enraged if Democrats pulled back now
these are the people who believe Trump
not only works directly for arch-villain
Vladimir Putin but also once had an
extramarital affair something the party
of polyamory now claims to oppose if
Pelosi wants to prevent these people her
party's deranged but faithful base from
staging an open rebellion she has no
choice but to continue with impeachment
and yet there is a problem with that as
much of Jeff Zucker supports impeachment
normal people find the whole thing
bizarre even voters who don't like
Donald Trump it didn't vote for him last
time don't think he ought to be removed
by Congress for starters they don't
understand what the crime is something
about Ukraine and Hunter Biden sounds
kind of shady but is it worse than the
opioid epidemic more dispiriting than
the endless war in Afghanistan more
pressing than health care costs which
are rising faster than wages
fill-in-the-blank the issues that
Congress could be handling if it weren't
for impeachment now impeachment doesn't
really rate on that list and by the way
isn't there an election 11 months away
why can't we wait till then if we want
to switch presidents isn't that how
democracy works those are some of the
questions that Pelosi and her party will
have to answer at some point probably
not too far from now and Pietschmann
will almost certainly turn out to be a
political disaster for them Donald Trump
will benefit Pelosi seems to know this
she didn't get to be Speaker because
she's bad at politics but she can't
acknowledge it out loud Pelosi is
trapped by the lunatics to her left
so like the British Army during the
retreat from Kabul she puts a brave face
on a doomed mission and fights on here
was her explanation this morning
let us begin where our founders began in
1776
when in the course of human events it
becomes necessary from one people to
dissolve the political bands which have
connected them with another with those
words
our founders courageously began our
declaration of independence from an
oppressive monarch for among other
grievances the Kings refusal to follow
rightfully past laws in the course of
today's events it becomes necessary for
us to address among other grievances the
president's failure to faithfully
execute the law it's just mesmerizing on
many levels but what did it mean exactly
well it was a metaphor Trump is a
slightly more orange version of King
George 1/3 Democrats are the Patriots
plotting to overthrow him with violence
if that strikes you as alarming Pelosi
is a few words of comfort a group of
18th century slaveholders she assures us
would have been completely in favor of
what she's doing James Madison the
architect of the Constitution warned
that a president might betray his trust
to foreign powers which might prove
fatal to the Republic another founder of
governor Morris feared that a president
may be bribed by a greater interest to
betray his trust he emphasized that this
magistrate is not the king the people
are the king uh-huh so James Madison has
given Nancy Pelosi his personal seal of
approval remember that the next time
Pelosi's acolytes try to pull Madison's
statue off its pedestal for crimes
against progressive orthodoxy for a
brief moment the founders of our country
are useful to the left so they're being
presented as heroes enjoy it while lasts
the framers Pelosi tells us worried that
corrupt Americans might take money from
foreign powers to do their bidding and
that class is why we need to impeach
Donald Trump get it wait a second
Trump didn't take money from Ukraine
under Biden did Trump has pointed that
out he was on James Madison side on that
score vigilantly policing bribery by a
hostile foreign power
and for that he must be removed from
office that's the Democratic Party's
position and if you're not sold yet
if you sense there might be a few links
missing from that logic chain Nancy
Pelosi has an answer for you it's not so
much an argument as it is a cliche bomb
a dense cluster of familiar phrases
designed to convey the impression that
important facts are being delivered and
profound thinking is taking place it's
like that old Don McLean's song drove my
chevy to the levee but the levee was dry
doesn't actually mean anything but it
kind of moves you anyway listen to Nancy
Pelosi's rendition of it a republic if
we can keep said Benjamin Franklin our
democracy is what is at stake the
president leaves us no choice but to act
because he is trying to corrupt once
again the election for his own benefit
the president has engaged in abuse of
power undermining our national security
and jeopardizing the integrity of our
elections so maybe we're being too
literal here but what is she telling us
Pelosi is telling us that in order to
honor the spirit of Benjamin Franklin we
must suspend our democracy in order to
preserve it well there was a time when
America the left was sharp and clear
eyed enough to see irony in a line like
that we've got to torch the village to
save it uh-huh sure we do make sense
liberals in 1975 would have laughed
Pelosi off the stage democracy means in
fact deciding things in elections not
star chambers that was obvious then but
somewhere along the way the left lost
interest in democracy and then gave up
on it completely by the time Obama
arrived they were bragging about how
they graduated beyond winning over
voters with conventional arguments and
promises going forward shifting
demographics was gonna win elections for
them now and forever
they gloated about that in public they
wrote triumphant books about it and then
out of nowhere Donald Trump proved them
wrong he left off the front page of the
New York Post and beat them in a
presidential election they didn't see
that coming nobody did the shock was so
profound it shattered them they never
recovered left turned against the
country that disappointed them and the
system that made it possible
opened the border eliminate electoral
college throw off the restraints and
erased the past whatever it takes to
regain power we are full
that can never happen again it was too
painful that's what they resolved like a
reformed drunk the Democratic Party got
religion Nancy Pelosi started talking in
fact a lot about prayer today I am
asking our Chairman to proceed with
articles of impeachment
I commend our committee chairs and our
members for their sombre approach to
actions which I wish the President had
not made necessary in signing the
Declaration of Independence
our founders invoked a firm reliance on
divine providence Democrats too are
prayerful join this Adam shifts somber
approach that's what Nancy Pelosi would
like you to recall for the past couple
weeks and appreciate the dignity that
bug-eyed lunatic from Burbank brought to
this process if you watch the
proceedings you'll remember it really
was like being in the room as Alexander
Hamilton composed the Federalist Papers
a tribute to representative government
and I would just say to people watching
here at home and around the world in the
words of my great colleague we are
better than that
adjourned a tsunami of falseness that
threatens to drown us all save that tape
when Donald Trump gets reelected we'll
have tangible evidence showing how
exactly it happened